so every once in a while you come across
something that just takes you completely
by surprise like you think you know how
water and gravity work right you turn on
the hose and water comes out and then
you see something like this I mean what
exactly is going on here if you think
the camera has something to do with it
you're right
today we're gonna look at a whole bunch
of illusions that mess with your visual
perception some rely on camera tricks
others require special lighting and some
you can even see with nothing but your
naked eye but first let's talk about how
we wound up building this thing
my producer Juno and I had seen
something like it online we did some
research and found that to make it
ourselves we would need a speaker rubber
tubing a stand a water source a sump
pump for circulating that water and a
lot of gaffers tape here's the thing we
built this contraption so we know how it
works and we'll get to that in a second
but we also wanted to know why it works
why our brains can be tricked into
seeing the water in this very specific
way so we called up David Eagleman he's
a neuroscientist at Stanford and an
expert on visual illusions so have you
seen one of these things before
oh yeah that is pretty amazing I love
that illusion yeah exactly it was it was
super fun to build but Juno and I are
trying to figure out like sort of why it
works like on a neuro mechanistic level
is that something you think you could
help us out with oh I'd love to yeah and
there's a class of illusions that are
like that if you just want to come down
to my office in Palo Alto we can build
some stuff here and I'll show you guys
some things yeah that'd be sweet so we
took apart our contraption drove down to
Palo Alto and put it back together with
Eagleman inside his office all right so
we pack this thing together see we're
going to do this all right
now here's the thing you can't actually
see this effect with the naked eye so
we're watching it through the cameras on
our phones here's why we're using a tone
generator to run a specific frequency in
this case 24 Hertz which is 24 cycles
per second through that big speaker when
the speaker plays the tone it vibrates
at the same rate
causing the hose and the water flowing
through it to undulate at the same
frequency to the naked eye it looks like
it's spraying everywhere and it is but
it's not spraying randomly if we set our
camera to match the rate at which the
water is moving then we get this here's
what it looks like to the naked eye and
here's what happens when we adjust the
cameras frame rate and if you manipulate
the frequency deliberately you can
produce even more effects so right now
our tone generator is pumping out 24
Hertz we're gonna offset that by 1 Hertz
and so now when I look at this through
my phone the corkscrew looks like it's
travelling up out of the bucket into the
tube what's actually happening with this
water we're capturing a view of it that
is no longer even and so it looks like
it's moving now of course the water
isn't actually climbing up into the tube
your brain is just telling you that it
is and that's because of something
neuroscientists call apparent motion
when the brain receives a series of
adjacent images in rapid succession it
interprets them as being in motion it's
the same reason old animations and
flipbooks work in video - what's
happening here is that the cameras frame
rate is just barely out of sync with the
vibration of the speaker so instead of
seeing the spiral in the same position
every twenty-fourth of a second we see
it in what looks like a slightly higher
position and when you string together
all those tiny shifts it gives your
brain the impression that the water is
spiraling slowly upwards or if you
adjust the frequency of the tone
generator slowly downwards now you don't
usually see this kind of effect on
camera but there is one
place that it pops up all the time and
that's when you see a wheel moving on a
car for example and that gave David an
idea why don't we hop in the car and
using the camera film the wheel as we're
driving and see if we can reproduce the
wagon wheel illusion okay now you may
not have heard of the wagon wheel
illusion but you have definitely seen it
so our producer Juneau is gonna be
hanging out the window with a GoPro on a
selfie stick okay David in the back has
a live view of what's happening oh geez
beautiful it's cool right here's what's
happening the frame rate on the camera
is perfectly matched with the rate of
the wheels rotation so every time it
captures an image the spokes appear to
be in the same position and just like we
saw with the spiraling water weird
things happen when the frame rate is
just slightly out of sync with the
motion of the object being filmed but
actually keep going so as you're going
straight here okay yeah it's beautiful
it's going backwards here at this speed
it's just going fully backwards right
here I'm doing a pretty bad job of
driving at a consistent speed which is
why the spokes go from looking like
they're spinning slowly backwards to
standing still to drifting slowly
forwards all in the span of a few
seconds with the spiraling water
illusion we flipped the switch and the
water immediately vibrated at the exact
frequency we wanted but here the rate at
which the wheel is rotating fluctuates
based on how slow or fast I Drive which
changes with the camera sees at a fixed
frame rate oh my god that's wild watch
that footage again but this time pay
attention to the wheels bolts I mean the
really wacky part I have just never
noticed this before is there are five
bolts and seven spikes and because of
the differences in the distances there
they are doing different things so the
bolts right now look like they are
moving backwards and the spokes at this
exact moment are not doing anything
they're just they're essentially still
but the bolts are zipping around like
crazy because your brain doesn't know
that that's actually spoke number one
and then spoke number two and spoke
number three in that position it just
looks the same to it
and the bulbs on the other hand are
changing position until your brain picks
the shortest direction and says oh okay
I think it must be rotating that way as
opposed to that way remember a parent
motion it applies here too because the
bolts in each frame appear to shift ever
so slightly counterclockwise your brain
interprets them as spinning backwards
okay so that was sweet illusion that's
requiring the camera to work right we
can't see with the naked eye right but
there is a way to do that yeah we can do
that essentially with a strobe light by
illuminating for us where we see the
thing and then we see the thing we see
every 24 you know 24 times a second we
could capture the same thing without a
camera right you actually show me you've
got like a little yeah so this is the
levitating water illusion so this has a
pumpkin so even though it looks like
that's one drop that's actually catching
one drop at that position and then
catching the next drop at a position
just above that next drop it of Decision
just above that so what you see because
of the strobing is this going up yeah by
switching the rate at which it's
dripping we give it get standstill you
can make you go the other way in slow
motion
so essentially you can change the rate
at which it's dripping and you can
change the rate at which the strobe
lights are flickering so the cool thing
to me about this illusion is that you
don't need a camera to make it work you
can actually see it with your naked eye
with a little help from the strobe light
yeah exactly it's because the strobe
light is illuminating though it's
turning on the world several times a
second just like a camera frame is doing
and because of that we can make the
drops stand still because we're catching
one drop and then the next drop in the
next drop in the same position that's
when we're turning on the illumination
so you can make it run back exactly if
you catch this next drop just a little
bit higher than your visual system says
well I saw that guy and I saw that it
must be the same guy it looks like it's
climbing up so you know normally in
evolutionary time we saw it things under
continuous sunlight err with fire light
or whatever so this is a very unusual
situation for our visual systems to have
to deal with where
it sees something illuminated and then
that goes away and the next time we see
illumination it happens to be something
in the exact same spot or really close
by it yeah there is an illusion that is
related to this in which you don't need
a strobe light at all
you don't need camera at all you can see
it under constant sunlight you can see
the direction of a moving object
reversing it's a very strange thing and
we can build that actually if you want
we can build that up yeah all right well
why don't you have a seat okay so the
key is find a spot that you can stare at
that's not moving in other words don't
track the dots with your eyes here's a
view of what I'm seeing if you haven't
already full screen this video we're
gonna run this shot for a long time so
you can try it for yourself
fix your eyes on the white dot and keep
them steady try not to let them follow
the black circles as they whip past now
try not to blink and be patient stare
long enough and something strange should
happen every so often the direction that
the dots are spinning will appear to
flip it only happens occasionally and
while it happens for some people more
than others the effect never lasts more
than a few seconds here's the difference
between what you're seeing here and the
spiraling water and wagon-wheel
illusions those effects happen at the
same time for everyone because the
camera is driving the illusion but in
this case everyone sees it a little bit
differently because it's not the camera
that's responsible for the effect it's
you did you get it to work if not don't
worry we've included an extended version
of this shot in the show notes for you
to try at home so what's going on you
might think this happens because our
brains process visual information the
way a camera does in discrete frames but
david says that's not the case okay so
what's to say that the frame rate at
which my brain processes it isn't just
changing all the time yeah good question
so in order to address that when I came
up with was a way to test whether your
brain is taking the screech snapshots of
the visual scene all at once and that
was a very inexpensive test that took $5
in a mirror do you want to try that yeah
okay I'm gonna ask you to scoot around
to that end of the table now what I have
here is a big mirror and I'm gonna put
this here so that you see two two drums
rotating now you should see them about
side by sides that would you see yeah
the question is do you see both drums
reverse direction at the same time when
you see reversal or do you see one drum
reverse and then a different drum
reverse and then the first drum reverse
again take a look the rotating dots on
the right are in the real world the ones
on the left are the reflection just like
last time focus on the white dot and
keep your eyes steady soften your gaze a
little bit and wait the mirror is
showing you a perfect visual double of
the original device and that is the key
to this experiment if our brains did in
fact process visual information the way
cameras do in discrete frames then you
would expect both sets of dots to always
switch directions at the same time but
that's not what happens
you have mechanisms in your brain to
detect leftward motion and those are
picking up on that and saying oh you
clearly have leftward motion in the
world but you also have mechanisms for
rightward motion and it turns out that
those rightward mechanisms can be fooled
by a lot of leftward motion like this
the right word guys get a little bit
activated by leftward motion so what
happens is when you stare at this motion
for a long time your brain is pretty
sure it's going to the left but it has a
little bit of a hypothesis that maybe
it's moving to the right and so those
are in battle with one another and so
every once in a while the right story
wins just a little bit now this is very
similar to other things that we've seen
like like with a cube that's drawn just
the wireframe of the cube network you
the Necker cube soon as you see it
coming out one way or you see it going
out the other way and they'll switch
back and forth but those happen to have
the same probability 50/50 chance that
it might be one way or the other this
has like a 95 versus 5% chance so this
is more rare you have to stare at it for
a while to see it come out once in a
while so you have populations of cells
in your brain that are fighting for both
stories and it's just a matter of which
population dominates the hill at any
given moment that's what you perceive
yeah and it's all because
your brain is locked in silence and
darkness it's not seeing any of this
directly it's putting together a story
of what's going on in the outside world
based on the little signals that it sees
that's why there's so many different
types of illusions and these illusions
aren't just for fun they reveal
interesting things about the way we're
wired and how he experienced the world
so in the end if our brains tell us
stories that messed with our perception
of reality that's not necessarily a bad
thing